>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Mary Oey: Good morning.
I am Mary Oey from
conservation division and welcome
to preservation week at
the Library of Congress.
Preservation week is an
initiative started in 2009
by several organizations, including
the library, to raise awareness
for preservation of
cultural heritage.
Today's event is our second and
last preservation week 2016 program,
and our 78th topics and
preservation series lecture.
Excuse me.
Andrew Robb is head of
Special Format Conservation
and oversees the care of the
library's 15 million photographs.
He is also responsible
for the library's preservation
emergency response team,
and serves on the library's
emergency management team.
He acts as the library's
point of contact
for federal emergency plans
related to cultural resources.
He has been a co-chair of
the emergency committee
of the American Institute for
Conservation, and is a member
of the National Heritage Responders.
Andrew received an MS in art
conservation with a major
in photograph conservation, and
a minor in paper conservation
from the University of Delaware
Winterthur Art Conservation Program.
Welcome Andrew.
[ Applause ]
>> Andrew Robb: Thank you Mary.
Do I have all the mics right?
Welcome everybody that's
in the auditorium,
as well as about 78
people out in the ether.
So I hope everybody can hear me.
We have three microphones, it
feels quite impressive up here.
So let's start.
So today's topic is about
heritage emergency management
and the Florence flood.
I've changed the title slightly
since we put up the announcement
because there's some things that
I'm going to talk about that are
from before the Florence flood.
But it's a good touchdown for how
things have developed both up to
that point, and after that point.
It really is a central moment
in both our field as well
as in the broader area
of emergency management.
So let's just review a little
bit about Florence flood.
Many of us saw the Zeffirelli film
yesterday, which is an excellent way
of just really getting into
the feeling of that moment
and how desperate and
horrible it was.
It was in November of 1966, and it
started because of heavy rainfalls
above Florence that came
down the Arno River and went
through the center of Florence.
It also flooded close to a third
of the northern part of Italy.
So Venice was also affected.
It was not just a local disaster,
it was a national disaster of very,
very large, it was very large.
Obviously Florence is a cultural
center, and an enormous amount
of cultural resources were damaged.
3 to 4 million books and
manuscript materials,
as well as close to
14,000 works of art.
And many of these truly
iconic works of art
that certainly grab
the world's attention.
As you can see on the
right, these are pictures
from a National Geographic
article from 1967 that was,
it's quite often cited as
a way of the continued,
people were continually interested
in this and it is quite difficult
to understand how impactful things
like that article were at the time,
in a time when we have the
Internet and cable news.
The images of this and the film
were quite important in terms
of conveying to people
the extent of the damage.
Extremely high waters, very, and
also moving at a very high speed.
So very destructive,
and full of heating oil.
So dirty, moving at great
force, at times over 20 feet.
This is the following day, the
rain started on November 3,
flooding started in the very
early morning of November 4
and this picture is probably
in the afternoon of November 4
or the following day on the
fifth, probably on the fourth.
You can see the Ponte Vecchio
to orient yourself back here.
The worst flooding is just,
if you're following the river,
just up the river here
and that's Santa Croche
where them an extensive number
of artworks were damaged,
and you can see that, you can
see the aftermath below you.
The north side of the river was more
badly affected than the south side
and that's why people
are able to gain access.
It's a little higher ground.
But you can see the
extent of the water
after the rainfall has stopped, it's
close to the height of the first,
the first story of the cloister.
So all of the artwork that's at
that level was submerged underwater.
Like a lot of emergencies
will have this recurrent theme
that while they happen
unexpectedly, they don't happen
in a completely random way.
Florence had had a series of
floods throughout the centuries.
Easily four other major
floods in 1333, 1557, 1966,
and 13 other minor
floods since 1557.
You can get a sense of the timing by
various markers throughout the city
that are marking the 1557 flood,
the 1966 flood, 1333 flood,
that these are certainly
witnesses as you're walking
through the the town, looking up
close to 20 feet up of the extent
of what can happen and had happened.
We saw a lot of this yesterday
when we were watching the movie
and just this the efforts
of just the,
of just reclaiming
the city, enormous.
Come back to this, but this
shows you sort of, you know,
even if by the first few days,
few weeks, lots of efforts
to stabilize very important
works of art
that were completely
submerged under water.
You can see here the line
of how high the water
got, so very extensive.
The Last Supper was
faced with paper,
a lot of paintings were treated
that way to stabilize them.
In this case, it was on a series
of panels, we'll come back
to this later, but was stabilized
and treated at a later time.
How much later, we'll
get into a bit.
So I said it wasn't only artworks,
it was also library materials.
What we would describe as a National
Library of Italy is actually
in Florence and it
was extremely damaged.
It was also in an area that
received a lot of flooding,
close to 70,000 rare
volumes and over a million
and a half general collection items.
And you can see the reading room
area is being used as a triage area
where things are coming
out from the stacks.
And this is where you get a
sense of those that came to help
and assist with the recovery.
The mud angels, and it was muddy,
it was muddy for days and weeks.
So it's, so that sort of gets
you through the initial response.
We saw a lot of that in
yesterday's viewing of the film.
The initial salvage, getting
things out from areas that,
so they could be stabilized
and treated.
The story for the Library of
Congress in many ways starts here
because our founding chief of
conservation, Peter Waters,
was at that time, not at the
library, he was still working
as a book binder in England.
But he was, he came to head the
recovery, the long-term recovery
and treatment of items
after the floods.
So this is a lab that he
set up to start that work,
and as part of that work, he brought
in colleagues Don Etherington,
Chris Clarkson, among others.
What's interesting is all three
of them eventually came here
and were essentially many
of our founding leaders
in the conservation division.
And I think we carry a
legacy of that experience
because of the way they set up
the lab and the way they thought
about dealing with scale,
and the way they thought
about dealing with
important objects.
It was very much formed in
the crucible of Florence.
You can see below on the left,
these are items of volumes
that still remain untreated,
but they're stabilized,
and we'll come back that theme.
It's very similar to
the Last Supper.
Items are stabilized, but
they may not be fully treated
for years, if not decades.
And I think this is something
that as we look back at Florence
and we look at other
more recent emergencies,
we should be more mindful of this
and speak more clearly
about that difference.
I'll talk about that in a second.
But these are stable, they're
not going to get worse,
but they're not fully treated.
They're shelved and can be
retrieved and treated as needed.
So this leads me to why
am I giving this talk?
I was not a mud angel.
I was about one, I was busy watching
baseball, as many of you know,
that's a great interest of
mine as is monochromatic images
which is also interesting to think
of how far back these
interests go in my life.
But I was here when Peter was here,
I'm right back here, all that person
with all that hair,
right there, that's me.
So I did get the privilege
of working with Peter
and interestingly we rarely talked
about Florence, we mainly talked
about the point system
and the computers
that were brought into the lab.
So, apples don't fall far from the
trees either, I spend a lot of time
in front of computers now.
But Peter's impact on the lab was
enormous and it was a real privilege
to be able to work with him and to
just understand where he was coming
from in terms of the
way our lab worked.
But as I said, I had an
interest in photography images
and I became a photograph
conservator, so again, that's,
wonder why would you become
interested in emergency response.
Well, partly because when you have a
lot of photographs, of which we do,
they're quite vulnerable and they're
the kind of objects that you worry
about when you have emergencies,
floods, or even smaller incidents.
And so pulling all this
together, after Florence 1975,
Peter published Salvage of
Water Damaged Library Materials
which is an incredibly useful
and practical book even today.
Something I still refer to
on a fairly regular basis,
just for practical common
sense ways of dealing
with large-scale emergencies.
Unfortunately, Klaus
Hendricks [assumed spelling]
at the National Archives
of Canada at the time,
and Brian Lesser [assumed spelling]
published a really important paper
about the recovery of photographs
in these kinds of incidents,
enormously good compliment to
this article, they really, I mean,
to Peter's book, excuse me, in 1983.
And so by the time I was
in school, graduate school,
this was a fundamental text for
me in terms of understanding how
to help and assist people as they
may ask questions or need assistance
in terms of an emergency.
The core thing that comes out of
Florence, among many core things,
besides the development
of professionalism,
of labs like our own, is a real
sense of what can we do better?
What tools can we use?
What kinds of technology can we use?
And it really comes down to
people really thinking hard about,
can we freeze materials,
dry them in other ways
so that we buy ourselves time so
we don't have to worry about things
like mold increasing damage,
because things are waterlogged?
And because of Peter and many
others that were focusing on how
to improve response and recovery
methods, we typically recommend,
particularly for library materials,
that we, that you freeze it.
If you have the scale and you have
the resources to not freeze it,
and to air dry it, and do, in
some cases, a full treatment,
that obviously is preferable.
But if you don't have
that, those options,
freezing is a very viable solution.
And it's something that now
we have a very robust set
of a whole industry around us and a
real sense of experience and scale
where this is a vacuum chamber
that is quite, quite large.
So this comes out of
a sense of hospitals,
law firms, people with records.
Emergencies happen frequently.
We don't always hear about them,
but water instances, they happen.
And a whole industry has
come out, since Florence,
surrounding the assistance of these
kinds of incidents and these kinds
of capacities exist in a way
that they did not at Florence.
So we'll circle back to the
Library of Congress where we are,
where Peter started the lab.
Where he initiated a lot of
important conservation approaches,
what we now call collection
stabilization,
which at the time we
called base conservation.
How to deal with scale.
How to deal with important
objects at the same time.
We have three very large buildings.
We have close to, I think a hundred
and fifty million objects located
on Capitol Hill in these
three buildings here.
Just to give you a sense if you're
unfamiliar with our buildings,
three very large buildings
full of collections.
And our experience then going
back with, so we have Peter,
Peter was at Florence, he
came and set up the lab.
But at the library we also have
another legacy that has to do
with we've experienced, oh sorry,
I'm getting ahead of myself.
These are some of the hundred
and fourty million things ranging
from Jefferson's, Thomas
Jefferson's original library,
our second founding library,
I'll get into that in a moment.
Iconic objects like
the Gutenberg Bible,
Declaration of Independence
draft, pre-Columbian objects,
musical instruments, photographs,
as well as many, many, many books.
Some of which are on
the floor unfortunately.
So let's go back to,
so where did we start?
Well, we started as truly a
legislative library in this part
of the original capital building.
Not a very large library, and
not a particularly expansive one,
and it was burned in
the war of 1812.
In 1814 the British came down
Maryland Avenue, burned the capital,
and the library was destroyed.
And why is this relevant for us?
Well in many ways, we are the
way we are because the decision
to purchase Thomas Jefferson's
library to replace it,
gave us the mandate
that we still hold
to have an encyclopedic collection
of human creativity and knowledge.
We are the only national library
that has such a broad mandate
in the sense that other national
libraries typically are collecting
in their, either their
nation or their language.
Close to two thirds of our
new acquisitions in terms
of just our books are
in foreign languages,
and we have an extremely
broad and collecting mandate,
both in terms of breadth and depth.
And that comes directly because of
the way we responded to the fire
and the loss of our
original library.
We grew very quickly during the 19th
century, suffered a number of fires,
and sadly many of the volumes
of Thomas Jefferson's original
library were lost in those fires.
And so the building of
the Jefferson building
in the late 19th century was
in direct response to that.
It has very little wood in it.
It's made out of metal,
stone, glass,
in ways that were really meant
to protect items from fire.
So we're very mindful of this, it's
why we have the collection we have,
it's why we have the
mission we have.
And we've continued to do this both
in terms of what Peter carried on,
in terms of, I'm including him
here as having worked in Florence.
Obviously he wasn't here at the
time, he had not quite gotten here,
but we do a lot of work in terms
of both outreach, assisting people,
training people, as well as,
as I'll get into a moment,
working on federal policy and
national policy on this issue.
We take it seriously,
and it's something
that we're quite committed to.
Not just in our part of the
library, but across the libraries,
as I'll refer to in a moment.
So we talk about broader,
take a step back and look
at federal institutions and
federal cultural institutions,
we are the first federal cultural
institution founded in 1800.
The Smithsonian follows us in 1846,
followed by the National Park
Service for our natural patrimony
that we have, national
archives is formed in 1934
to aggregate federal records in a
way that had not been done before,
and we have the National
Gallery in 1941.
There are a few other
federal cultural institutions
and I'm not leaving them out,
well I'm leaving them out,
but I'm including them here.
I'm not including them here because
as we we'll see as we start getting
into federal initiatives that
have to do with Heritage emergency
and response, these are
the core federal agencies
that both have the technical
experience as well as the background
of having experience either
losses or contributing
to other kinds of efforts.
These are the core five.
We talked about support
agencies, there was really little,
there was really very
little federal support
for collections before the 1960s.
And we have the creation of
NEA in 1965, NEH in 1965,
IMLS in 1996 formally, but has
antecessors in 1976 and 1956.
These are support agencies
in the truest sense,
they do not have collections.
They don't, they are not
responsible for them,
but they support others
who hold those things.
And we have a very decentralized way
of caring for our cultural heritage.
Other countries have
ministries of culture
where the national library not
only runs its national collection,
but it runs all the
libraries underneath it.
We don't follow that
model, and NEA, NEH,
IMLS are ways that we support
the efforts that are happening
at a state or local level.
And they're modeled after the
National Science Foundation
which was formed in 1950 to do
the same kind of thing in support
of science and other
kinds of efforts.
One of the reasons why this is going
on, if you're looking at other kinds
of efforts that we've made that
really are, I think, are important.
The monuments men and the,
essentially the monuments fine arts
and archives is our formal name,
organized to protect
initially things
in the European theater during
World War II, both to protect them
from being in a warfront and
also in repatriating items
that had been stolen or
looted during the war.
So this is something that as
we're looking at federal policy,
is an important way that
even in times of war,
there was a recognition
that cultural patrimony,
cultural heritage was an
important, was something important
and important enough that, in fact,
as commander of all of the forces
of allies General Eisenhower
commanded
that all officers take this into
account and officers were seconded
to work with them to protect
these items if it all possible.
One of our founding
fathers in the field
of conservation is George Stout,
and he's here with the helmet
and the N. He was in the Navy,
he was very proud of that.
And there, this is where they're
recovering the Ghent altarpiece
that had been removed
during the war.
So in this way, very similar iconic
artworks that attempts were made
to save them during the war.
And remember this is really
in the period of 1943 to 1945.
So to get into federal legislations,
so we have cultural institutions
but we're decentralized in the sense
that those cultural institutions
have a primary responsibility
for their collections.
They don't have as strong a
priority in terms of caring
for other people's collections,
we have a cleaner divide
than in other places.
We do have federal legislation
that starts coming into play
to protect both items that
are in the nation that we feel
like are worthy of caring for them.
So we have the National Historic
Preservation Act of 1966.
And it has some antecessors or
antecedants in 1935 and 1960,
but essentially we create a
national register of historic sites.
This is quite important as
we get into some of the ways
in which we respond to emergencies.
And it's essentially been amended
to include not just historic sites,
but also archaeological
objects, shipwrecks,
Native American material,
both in grave sites as well
as archaeological sites, maritime
areas, battlefields, lighthouses.
And all of these have
a real legal protection
and federal money is involved, and
it requires a review of the impact
of any kind of federal
action on these areas.
And this really comes out of a
sense during the 60s that because
of increased building, postwar
building, the highway system,
a number of things where the federal
government is actually spending a
fair amount of money that
items and important buildings
and environments are being lost.
And so this is a way
to protect them.
It doesn't always mean the
federal government owns them,
usually it means that they don't.
It just means that these
things have a status
that requires review before
federal action takes place.
So the national register is
something you'll see plaques.
If you go over to St. Mark's Church
which is right behind the Adams
[assumed spelling] building,
you'll see it's on
the national register.
And it's precisely on
the national register
because St. Mark's didn't want to
be the next church that got torn
down as the library
continued its march east.
It's there, that's on the
national register to stop
that from happening in theory.
One of the things though
that's interesting
if you read the highest level
language of, of the NFPA act,
it describes that the Secretary of
the Interior is authorized to expand
and maintain a national register
of historic places comprised
of district sites, building
structures, and objects,
significant in American history,
architecture, archaeology,
engineering, and culture.
So that seems like that
would cover objects,
but in fact it doesn't
cover objects.
Generally, the notion is
is that objects have to be,
they have to be associated
with that site to be covered
by the national register.
And in fact commentary,
not so much legislation,
but certainly commentary on how to
implement this explicitly describes,
excuse me, that objects that are
in a museum are not appropriate
for the national register.
So when you're talking
about what these laws do,
essentially the built environment,
things that are outdoors,
have a lot of protection.
Things that are indoors,
collections, objects,
are not protected in the same way.
And we'll see why that's
important in a second.
A comparable set of
legislation happened in 1970,
the National Environmental
Protection Act.
And this is something when
whenever you hear on the news
that there's a project
going on, they're waiting
for an Environmental Impact
Assessment or some kind
of environmental statement
about what the project will
do, it comes from this law.
So between 1966, 1970, we have two
fundamental acts that describe how
to take care of the built
environment and how to take care
of the natural environment.
And the human environment
comes in to play with NEPA
because the human environment
can include some kinds
of cultural resources, like
cemeteries in particular,
where they're part
of that environment
so that you have a slight
crossover between these two acts.
But again, it does not include
what we would generally consider
as collection objects.
These projects, in particular, we
have another tie to at the library
in that the documentation around
these historic structures,
the sets of legislation
that have to do
with historic preservation include
the historic American buildings
survey, the historic
American engineering record,
and the historic American
landscape survey.
And all of those are
Department of Interior,
National Park Service projects, that
document that environment and copies
of those items, those drawings
come to us at the library
and we serve them as
part of our collections.
So we have a very direct link
to that legislation in the sense
that we benefit from that
and build our collections
around those activities.
This is an interesting example
of St. Michael's Cathedral
in Sitka, Alaska.
It was one of the first buildings
in Alaska to be done as a part
of the HABS work, and
it burned down.
And this is the church that was
built from the HABS drawings.
It was rebuilt using this, the
material that we, that we hold here.
Landscape survey is somewhat newer,
but it builds on that and it's a way
of documenting a, those
kinds of landscapes
that are protected in
the 1970 legislation.
So this leads us to something
that's really interesting about,
at least in the United States, what
do we call all of this material
that is generated in terms of
human creativity, human knowledge,
that those, that's what we
use in our mission statement.
Is it art, is it cultural resources,
is it heritage, is it collections,
is it historic materials, historic
properties, material culture?
Generally speaking, all
of these terms get used.
Increasingly, heritage is being
used as that term to encompass all
of those things, but
keep in mind that all
of those things have different
legal status in the way
that we respond particularly
in emergencies.
That's why I'm bringing this up.
This is not just an American
issue, it's an international issue.
I was at a conference
earlier in the spring
where we easily spent a few hours
talking about what culture is,
how you take care of
it, how you define it,
how you do it in a way
that's appropriate.
If you're doing response, how you're
including all the stakeholders
in a cultural interaction.
It can get quite complicated.
You can think of things in a
hierarchy, national treasures,
historic materials,
personal property.
And this is something I
want to emphasize too,
that while all I've been talking
about are essentially things
that are in collections, people
have their own collections.
Families have their own collections.
And that becomes an issue too
in how we respond in emergencies
and how we use our resources.
So let's switch slightly
to talk about some terms
about emergencies and disasters.
Florence is a disaster, and it's
the kind of disaster that it's sort
of a keystone if you're looking
at the history of the field.
A definition, it's something
where you have severe property
damage deaths and multiple injuries.
And it can be from now in our,
excuse me, in our thinking,
it can be caused by many
different types of of reasons.
It can be a natural disaster, it
can be a technological accident,
it can be a human caused event,
an act of war, terrorism,
those are things that
can all cause disasters.
Emergencies tend to be a word that
is somewhat less catastrophic,
but it's something that
requires responsive action
to protect life or property.
And then you can go a level down, if
you're looking for a generic word,
you can use the word
incident to describe something
that might be a disaster,
might be an emergency,
or might be actually something
that requires response
but isn't actually even
rising to the level of this,
it's a level down, but it's a more
generic term and I'll try to use
that word as much as I can.
So similar to our history, our
timeline with cultural institutions,
federal legislation about cultural
property, emergency legislation,
it has a similar arc, for many,
many decades the federal government
really does not have a lot
of legislation around this.
It doesn't really build up
legislation to protect things
at a broad level, it's
devolved essentially
to states and local groups.
The Civil Defense Act in 1950
changes that, it's a response
to the Cold War and it's
very focused on acts of war,
the Cold War, fears over atomic war,
it's a very, very specific approach
that does not include
natural disasters.
And it is only through a series
of pretty catastrophic disasters
in the 1960s, a very bad earthquake
in Alaska, Hurricane Camille,
Hurricane Betsy, that the Disaster
Relief Act is passed in 1970
that tries to create ways that
the federal government responds
to emergencies.
The National Governors Association
in 1978 and 79 really focused
on this and say that, well you've
done this, but you're not helping
up enough, it's not coordinated.
There are over a hundred
agencies that get involved
on a national level and
yet it's not coordinated
in a particularly good way.
And that led to the
creation of FEMA in 1979.
And the founding of FEMA
created two important concepts
that we still follow
today, excuse me.
The comprehensive emergency
management notion,
that is an all hazards approach.
We're not just going to confine our
planning to one type of disaster,
we're going to create one
system that can respond
to all kinds of disasters.
And we're going to have a structure,
in this case incident command
structure, that is scalable
from the smallest incident
to the largest catastrophe.
We're going to have a single
comprehensive approach,
and that's important when we start
talking about cultural property.
The Stafford Act of 1988 truly
codifies what we choose to do
with FEMA and the executive agencies
that respond to emergencies.
So the Stafford Act
is still referred to,
and the Stafford Act is the way
in which we respond to emergencies
and the various plans we have, are
an outgrowth of that legislation.
There's a federal response
plan first drafted in 1990.
It truly is the first comprehensive,
what we would call, emergency plan.
It's quite focused on
civil defense, but it is,
it is the first real plan.
We then have a national
response plan in 1999
that incorporates a number
of what are called
emergency support functions.
And the key thing here is that the
emergency support function notion
still exists today.
Cultural property is in what, is
in emergency support function 11
which is for natural and
agricultural products in 1999.
Like for a variety of reasons
it makes sense that in 2008,
ESF 11 creates a fourth
section that is
for natural and cultural resources.
And that's the first time
in a comprehensive way the
cultural property is included
in our thinking at a national level.
We can go back to that monuments
men experience and these other sense
of legislation and ways
of protecting things,
but in terms of how we respond in
an emergency, it isn't until 2008
that we truly have things explicitly
described of what we're going to do.
And the key thing there is that a
lot of the focus of even plans today
and strategies and
approaches to responding
to emergencies today is very focused
on where we have legislation,
that is our built and
natural environment.
It is not nearly as prescriptive
about what we should be doing
with cultural property that is
inside buildings, collections,
and that's because there is
no legislation around that.
So that's one of the things
where we continue to be involved
with these various plans.
The national response framework as
well as the disaster response frame,
the national disaster response
framework which came out in 2011,
which has a recovery
support function related
to natural and cultural materials.
So we serve on that
committee in part to be,
remind people that while many
agencies have authorizations
and budgets for taking
care of historic properties
and natural environments
and mandates to do that,
we're there as a voice for the items
that are not protected
by legislation.
And it's not that these plans
don't mention it or include it,
but it's an important
thing to keep in mind
that we don't have full complement
of the resources that we,
that our historic structures
and other things have.
So let's go a little bit into
emergencies, about half way,
people are going to come first.
This is a very straightforward
safety first kind of notion,
it isn't just a national
policy issue,
it happens at institutional
level or even in a lab level.
Then take care of buildings,
and then you take care of things
or collections or cultural property.
So this is something that's
also part of that hierarchy,
that's part of that
comprehensive approach.
And there is a real
tension that's similar
to that natural disaster
civil defense tension
of should we have one plan
or a, two different plans,
should we have them be
different or the same?
There's an ebb and flow in
FEMA policy and national policy
about that on a civil defense,
natural disaster front,
there's the same thing
that happens here
of should we really
even be including things
like cultural property in this?
And I'll explain why
that has prevailed.
Let's go, let's just talk a little
bit about what we do when we talk
about emergency management.
Emergency management as a field,
as a profession didn't really start
until the creation of FEMA.
That notion of a comprehensive
approach,
that notion of a scalable
approach are core parts
of what emergency managers do, they
did not exist certainly at the time
of Florence and they didn't really
exist until the early 1980s.
There are four key components
to that preparedness, response,
recovery, and mitigation.
It's important to keep this in
mind, you'll see particularly
in early preservation, conservation
literature about emergency,
they'll use one of these
terms, preparedness,
planning, response, recovery.
And really what they should be,
the word they really should be
using is collection emergency risk
management or heritage
emergency management
or art emergency management,
but it's a cycle,
they're all interrelated, you
need to be doing all of them,
you shouldn't be focusing
just on one of them.
And this is in for
a number of reasons,
but part of it is a practical one,
emergency managers, our plans,
our national policies, our
work within this framework,
and by far the fastest way to think
about this is to use
medical analogy.
Preparedness are the kinds of things
you do to take care of yourself
when you're not sick, but to
keep yourself from being sick.
They could be things like going
to the doctor, having checkups,
having health insurance,
taking care of yourself.
Response is what you do when
something happens to you.
And this is the important
distinction
between response and recovery.
When 911, when you call 911,
that's obviously response.
When you start getting treated in
the ambulance going to the hospital,
and that starts being
recovery to some extent,
but it clearly is also part
of a response function.
As you get into recovery,
you're in the emergency room,
there's more assessment,
there's some triage that's done,
some assessment, some treatment,
but the goal at that stage
of the emergency room cycle
is get you stabilized.
It's not to fully treat you,
it's to get you stabilized.
You have, you are not going
to get worse, you're alive,
and now some other doctor,
someone else can take care of you.
They can move on to other people
that have life-threatening
situations.
So a component of recovery is
rehabilitation and it's interesting
in many early parts of
emergency literature
in the conservation field,
this notion of recovery
and rehabilitation is stated.
But over time, it gets less
priority, it gets less attention,
and I think that's too bad and
it's one of the things where we're,
I think that's where
we're focusing on now
and Florence is an
interesting lesson in all that.
Recovery can take a long time
and that's not surprising.
If you suffer a major health
catastrophic event like a stroke
or a heart attack and you
live, you fully expect
that you will have a long
period of rehabilitation
and you might not ever
fully recover.
And that's a very similar
kind of approach
that happens with cultural property.
It's going to take a long time.
These stages overlap,
it's very confusing,
you can have response from,
like say, a people point
of view start happening and
end much before you even get
into the collection space
to start recovering it.
So these terms are very confusing.
This is a well-known
discussion point in all
of the emergency management
literature.
And so they overlap, it's confusing,
it's chaotic, and it's important
to keep in mind those terms and to
understand that they will overlap
and that long-term recovery really
will go on for months, if not years.
One of our conundrums in
cultural property area is
that we have a very limited amount
of time before we start seeing
increased damage from an incident.
Because almost every incident
involves water in some way,
either as part of the
incident or as part of the way
of treating incident,
and, say, a fire,
or as part of some
collateral component.
It can be the cause, as in a
flood, but it can also just be part
of how you're putting out a fire.
Water is a big problem.
Cultural properties, often organic
and mold is a huge, huge issue,
and we don't have that one.
I'm trying to work on this
theme of golden hundred hours.
It's sort of similar to the
golden, I think it's three
or four hours you have if you
have a stroke or heart attack,
you need to get to the hospital.
And that isn't to say that you
shouldn't go to the hospital
after that period, but your
chances of a full recovery are less.
This is just the physical
reality of the way mold
and the environment works
on inorganic material.
So this 3 to 4 day period is a very
tight window when you're talking
about particularly a catastrophic
event, but it's a reality.
And it's something that really
focuses us so much on planning
and preparedness because we'd like
to avoid this in the first place.
One of the other things that
happens with recovery is that even,
you know, as I go back
to here, you know,
things start returning
back to normal.
When you start having a building
that's completely renovated
and done, people are really
tired of that incident
and they want it to be done.
So usually with catastrophic
emergencies and disasters,
there's some sort of marker
that indicates when people,
in their minds, most
of them are done.
And so with Florence, it's
an exhibition in 1972.
There was a very large incident that
was about Florence restored, 1972.
There was a lot of culture material,
and there still is to some extent,
cultural material that's not
fully recovered or treated.
But it's something to be mindful of
too that one of the disadvantages
of freezing or other approaches
is that it leaves us in a position
where we have a, we often
have a great deal of work
after most people consider
everything done.
A lot of these notions
are now enshrined
in the relatively new national
disaster recovery framework.
And it outlines how this
may, how this rolls out,
and this is incredibly important
because as we're integrated
into this, it allows us to be
able to describe in a better way
where we are and how
we fit into this.
And how so much of what our
work is an immediate level is
with stabilization and not
necessarily with full recovery,
that rehabilitation is something
that we have to do in the long-term.
And that's certainly the case
with the Vasari Last Supper.
It was still under treatment in 2013
and it was only earlier this year
that the full treatment was
completed, almost 50 years later.
And that goes to the books.
Most of the rare books that
were in the national library
in Florence have been treated.
But there's a good chunk of
probably close to 8000 books
that still remain in this
condition and need to be treated.
It's part of long-term recovery and
we should be more explicit and clear
about our expectations when we
talk about what we;re trying to do
in emergency situations,
what the outcome will be,
what the expectation will be, and
what we mean when we say stabilize.
So let's just summarize
a little bit.
We know that we have a lot
of disasters in our country.
It's across the country.
This is all of the
federally declared emergencies
that the Stafford Act describes
how to do, from 1965 until 2003.
A pretty good span of time,
almost 40 years of time.
You can see that there's
virtually no part of the country
that isn't near or
affected by some kind
of presidentially declared
emergency.
That's a pretty significant bar
and some places have a lot of them.
Not surprisingly Gulf
Coast, earthquake areas,
where there's a lot of
snow, a lot of bad weather.
We know we're going to
have disasters and we know
that we have cultural material
in all of these places.
The national register has almost,
it's in the hundreds of thousands
of things on the national register.
If we're talking about
national parks,
talking about cultural institutions,
they're in almost every county
that's delineated on this map.
And we know unfortunately from
heritage preservation health index
from 2005 that we have a
real lack of preparedness.
That institutions,
particularly small ones,
do not have disaster
plans that are, that,
where you have trained
staff to implement them.
People are not ready and
that's not good if you're going
to have all these disasters.
And Hurricane Katrina
really pointed that out.
That while we made a lot of
advances, particularly in our field
in terms of a profession that
did not really exist at the time
of Florence, or was at the
very beginning of existing,
we have a lot of literature,
we have a lot of experience,
as with emergency managers, we
have a field that has expertise
and knowledge that should be able
to handle these kinds of situations,
but we lack structures,
infrastructure,
and resources to sometimes
do what we know we can do.
And Katrina really
pointed that out in 2005.
It really, really, really was
a disaster that was eye-opening
in the sense of all of the
things that we had done.
It was an eye-opening thing
to see how far short we fell.
It was an enormously large regional
disaster, it covered many states.
And one of the great American cities
was under close to 80 percent water,
very similar to Florence.
And while the cultural impact was
not quite as great as Florence,
it was certainly significant.
As was the human cost and the
way in which we responded both
as a federal government
and as a nation.
There were a number of things
that came out of the lessons
from Katrina, and it's one of
I think the the stronger traits
of American emergency management
in general is we do learn
from the past, we make changes,
we attempt to make things
better from what we've learned.
FEMA had become part
of DHS after 9/11,
but it was made more
independent after Katrina
so that it can really focus on
emergency management at large.
Also some other fundamental things
that happened where response used
to be at strictly a state
level, and it was hard
to coordinate across states.
Now that's allowed, and by far
the most important thing that came
out of Katrina was that public
assistance funding, that's described
in the Stafford Act, was
extended to cultural institutions.
That is cultural institutions that
are nonprofits, that need resources
to start recovery or
to start a response.
Those have to be applied for,
you don't get those immediately,
but typically in a
presidential declaration,
public assistance is one
of the phases and one
of the things that's authorized.
And in the past, cultural
institutions generally could not
apply for that.
It was something that they had to go
to the small business
administration for support.
So Katrina and that legislation
did get expanded in a way
that really did allow for items
that aren't protected in other ways
to receive some sort of
response in an organized way.
It also showed that just
from the sheer scale,
that you have less
control, the bigger it is.
And you need to be as
prepared as you can be
and do what you can if you can.
One of the things that also changed
after Katrina was the heritage
emergency national task force.
Originally, the task force
was focused on the wheel
and essentially information and
documents that people could use.
But it was not really
a proactive responder
in the sense of emergencies.
And it really has transformed itself
into a group of organizations,
Library of Congress is one of them,
that collectively represent the
cultural heritage in our nation
and try to gather information
in how to respond
to incidents that happened.
I was at a call a few weeks
ago about the flooding
in Louisiana around the King River.
So this is something
that's really changed.
Where this is a small organization
focused on sort of publications,
it's really transformed
itself into a way
that we can respond to emergencies.
Heritage preservation has come on
some hard times and fortunately one
of the things that has happened is
that while heritage
preservation no longer exists,
this whole task force has now
been taken on by the Smithsonian.
So it's an incredibly
important organization
that ties together
the cultural partners,
be they historic properties,
be they museums,
be they libraries and archives.
The alliance for response is another
historic preservation effort that's
been folded into the FAIC, and
it organizes at a local level.
So that at a city level and a
regional level, there are people
that are focused on response
for cultural materials.
We have the Haiti, oh and I
should add, I've left this
out even though I mentioned it in my
introduction, that another component
of this is that the
FAIC started what
at the time was the collections
emergency response team
of which I'm a member, that's
now called the National
Heritage Responders.
That is a group of people
that can be sent nationally,
sometimes internationally,
as they were for the Haiti
cultural recovery project,
to support recovery
and response efforts.
Doesn't have a great deal of funds,
but it does have a trained cadre
of people, about 100 people that can
go to different places, be deployed
and that technical expertise,
there's now a mechanism
to deploy it.
And that certainly did
not exist at Katrina,
and Katrina really started that.
The Smithsonian has
really taken a lead lately
in cultural emergency
management projects,
in part because of
their peculiar identity
as a federal entity, as
opposed to an agency.
Their trust funds allow them
a flexibility and a nimbleness
that not all other agencies have.
And they really took
the lead in the response
to the devastating
earthquake in Haiti in 2010
and initiated the cultural
recovery project
and a cultural recovery center
with training and assessment
that included the National
Heritage Responders,
but also a large number
of Smithsonian staff.
It's a noteworthy accomplishment.
AIC followed this model after
hurricane, or super storm Sandy,
forgive me, a culture recovery
center that was in Brooklyn.
And this is again a distinction
about when we're talking
about these different phases that
we need to be mindful of that,
that in this case we're
really talking about recovery.
A lot of the response was really
done by alliance for response team
in New York City, in particular, and
that we really were in a position
of helping people in
long-term recovery.
Another thing that the Smithsonian
has really been focusing on because
of Corey Wegner [assumed
spelling] is how
to safeguard cultural
heritage in areas of war.
It goes back to obviously
the monuments men.
Corey's been a dogged advocate for
this since her experience in Iraq
as an officer, and she's
continued to do that
and the Smithsonian has
brought her in the fold
and they've really been making an
enormous amount of effort to build
on what happened in Haiti, but also
to help with heritage that's at risk
in places like [inaudible].
So what now?
You know we're in a
very different place
in some respects from Florence.
We have resources, we have
experience, we have knowledge.
What do we need?
Well one of the things I feel
like we need is we need to know
when we have an emergency,
where it is.
And we need, in the sense of
where are our collections at risk?
Where are our institutions at risk?
What do we have, where is
it, and has it been damaged?
I mean I was just in the call that
I was on where we had questions
about things on a historic
register that we didn't know,
we didn't know exactly what
was in the affected area
and we didn't know if
it had been damaged.
We need to do a better job of that.
We need to be more resilient.
We need to work on
what, in some respects,
people call weak relationships,
that is not your primary
relationship,
but the people you know.
And the most vulnerable
institutions are small ones
where they don't have a cadre of
helpers or people that are aware
of them and maybe a
small historical society
that has a very small
staff of maybe even one.
We need to foster more relationships
so that those people not
only can ask for help,
but even if they don't ask for help,
people know that they're
there and will help them.
And frankly all institutions
need more staff.
The reason that we don't have as
much work on emergency planning
as we should is I think because
staffs are under a lot of pressure
and staffs are generally
below the high watermark
that they had in better times.
It's going to be real
hard to create those plans
if you don't have a lot of staff.
And we need to work
as, we need to focus
on vulnerability as an importance.
Do we want to focus on the
most vulnerable institutions?
Or do we want to focus on
the most important items?
How do we balance that out?
We can do both, but how
do we set our priorities?
How do we do triage?
Kazuna [phonetics] is a term that
I learned when I was in Japan.
I went to Japan in 2011 after
the earthquake at the request
of the National [inaudible] Library
and it's a notion of fellowship
and relationships in
difficult times.
And I think that's that element that
I think we can foster as we focus
on developing plans
and relationships.
Alliance for response is an
excellent grassroots way to do that.
How do we make those connections
between those folks, people at,
say, at the national level?
How do we integrate this in a way
so that we're ready
and we're resilient?
Let's take just a look at a
project that's really interesting
in Washington state.
They've been really focusing
on this mapping issue.
And they have a GIS
system and a mapping system
that basically maps the whole state
in various ways assessing risk.
And so one of them is
looking at an earthquake 7.2
that would happen in Seattle.
So right here, right
in this area where all
that red is, right in there.
This is Seattle right there
and there's, that's the water,
Seattle's over here,
a high risk area.
So one of the things they've done is
they've started to focus on mapping
where things are and
how they might be.
So what would happen if there
was a 7, how severe would a 7.2,
this is the scenario, this is an
earthquake, it would be centered
around Seattle and have
this ring around it.
And as you'll see on the right
side, they've added hospitals.
This is where all the
hospitals are on this map,
and they're mapped
in degree of damage.
And this takes into
account a number of things.
It takes into account not just,
well that it's in the zone,
but why is this, why are these,
why are these blue even though
they're in the worst area?
These are newer hospitals.
They're well-built.
They're seismically prepared.
They are ready.
This hospital knows that,
they can incorporate
that into their planning, and
if you're trying to respond
to hospitals being damaged in the
area, these are not going to be
as high on your list
necessarily as these.
They've done it for schools.
There are a lot of
schools in this area,
but this gives you the same sense.
This is something, it's a tool
that both can be used in terms
of response, in terms of
where are the schools?
How concerned should
we be about them?
But also what kind of school it is.
There's a lot of data behind this.
But also for schools to get
ready, then they know I'm at risk,
I'm in a really seismically
active area,
my building is old, I
need to do something.
These are things that we don't have
for cultural institutions
and we should.
It can be done.
It's just a matter of who
does it and a will to do it,
but we spend a lot of time
on our national emergency
task force calls trying
to just define what got damage
and what might be damaged.
We should not be in that situation.
We should do a better job and
we should do this kind of thing.
It would help us with our
planning, it would help us
with our preparedness, and it
would help us make the case
for why these institutions
may need more staff
to do these kinds of things.
And to keep them engaged in that
process of emergency preparedness
and response and recovery training.
We spend a lot of time on that here,
as many of my audience members are
on our emergency response team.
We spend a lot of time on this
because we want to be ready.
And that's where we
need to support smaller,
more vulnerable institutions
that need that support.
And we should keep in
mind that we may have
to make some difficult
decisions about what we recover,
when we recover it, but we should
also be informed by Florence
that despite a very devastating
flood and despite a passage
of 50 years, that all of their
major artworks are treated now
with the completion
of this treatment.
And it did happen 50 years
later, but it had been stabilized
and we need to make a
better case for what we mean
when we say, I've treated it.
I've completed the recovery effort.
We recruit, we save the object,
but we may need to rehabilitate it
and that may take significant
time and funds,
but that's just the reality
of the way these things work.
And the illustration of the books
on the side, it's the same thing.
There are thousands of books
that still need to be treated,
but they're stable and they
will eventually be completed.
So with that, I have a
lot of people to thank.
Many of you are on this list and
if you feel that you should be
on this list, please
tell me [laughter].
It's a lot of people.
This goes back to the
Kazuna [phonetic] principal.
There are a lot of people that you
get to know doing this kind of work,
working in this kind of area.
And it's really important, you'll
see this whole column here,
all of these people here are
library folks that have nothing
to do directly with collections,
they take care of our building,
they take care of our
infrastructure, they keep us safe,
but we have a very integrated
approach with collection security.
It ranges from physical security to
emergency response to environment.
It's a core part of
what we do and all
of those folks deserve
a lot of credit.
And for those out in web land,
if you want to contact me,
this is the way you can do that.
You can send your praise
or your arrows my way.
I really look forward to
getting everybody's feedback
and I know we're almost
done with the time,
but I'm happy to take any questions.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, it's lunch time,
people are hungry.
Jeanie.
>> Just a point of
clarification about the Smithsonian
because of course they are
working with FEMA and the person
at the Smithsonian is
actually, works for FEMA
but has been appointed to
Smithsonian, is that not correct
or am I misunderstanding?
I thought that Lori Foley
she actually works for FEMA,
but she's been signed
to Smithsonian,
is that right or am I incorrect?
>> Andrew Robb: That's
the current status.
Lori Foley used to work at the North
East Document Conservation Center.
She was co-chair of the
emergency committee with me,
while I was at ICI I'd
talk with her frequently.
She then went to heritage
preservation and as part
of how the different task
and heritage preservation were
devolved, she was hired by FEMA.
But the understanding is that,
I understand is that that,
while she's detailed to the
Smithsonian now, that at some point,
I think the expectation is that
her position will actually transfer
to the Smithsonian, but
that this was done as a way
of just making that
transition faster.
>> And I was just trying to make
that connection between FEMA
and the Smithsonian and
to clarify that from you.
>> Lori's actually online.
>> Andrew Robb: Hi Lori.
She can correct me if I've
got those details wrong.
Yes.
>> How long were you in Japan
helping with recovery efforts?
>> Andrew Robb: So that's
the interesting thing.
The conversation started, the
request started in late February,
but I did, or excuse me, late March,
because the earthquake
was in March, March 11th.
The request sort of
came in late March,
but I didn't get there
until September.
So that's one of those things
too about there's a difference
between what you do when you
start having a conversation
with people right after this
happens, with what happens
when you're there and really people
are in a long-term recovery mode.
There still were a lot of
devastation, a lot of debris removal
but when we went up
to the Tohoku region,
I was there for about a week.
It was really something of
just, more than anything else,
being the person to listen
and to encourage them.
The technical part
of what they're doing
in recovering those personal
photographs is really amazing
and I think it was something that,
I mean, I gave a very similar kind
of talk there in terms of what I
see in, from the response in Japan.
Broadly for culture material, it's
very narrow, and they don't have
as expansive a way
of interconnecting
these different needs.
There isn't something like the
heritage emergency national task
force, the cross professional ties,
cross institutional ties are weaker,
and it really creates problems
when they have a very robust list
of national treasures, but things
fall off the list very quickly.
So things like legal records
are, fell to the Department
of Justice to take care of.
And it was not a very organized
response, although ambitious,
and it's the kind of thing that
hopefully, that was helpful to them.
The encouragement I know
was helpful, but I was there
for about two weeks overall
and even at that time, I mean,
it shows you too with
something like that,
it really was a national disaster.
I mean, when I was there,
there were power shortages,
other kinds of issues.
It was still even six months
after an eye-opening experience
for how devastating
something like that can be.
And I think a real reminder that
while you can prepare as much
as you can, you can be in situations
where even months after the fact,
you're still falling short on
resources and other things.
>> Oh. What is the current planning
with respect to climate change
and all of the projections
with respect
to sea level rise, stronger storms?
>> Andrew Robb: Well, I mean that's,
you could go back, if I go back to,
if I go back to this
kind of model, I mean,
that's why the mapping
is so important.
I mean you can take
a model like this
and you can apply it
to sea level change.
Whether you want to talk about
storm surges from hurricanes,
or you want to talk about a rising
sea, rising water levels, you know,
it's a part of risk management.
And if you're near
one of these areas
that should be something
your mindful of and it's why
on the emergency management
side it's so important to have
that comprehensive approach
because you should be able
to then adjust your
risk assessment to take
into account things like that.
But certainly, proximity to
water is a huge risk factor,
Florence tells you that.
I mean Florence isn't going to move,
but cultural material that's
near the river is vulnerable.
As would be things near coasts
or where sea levels are rising.
Okay. I think we're done.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.